let's go next to justin from new york
justin you're on the air
hello
hello
oh can you hear me or
yes i can
okay hey david how are you first time
first time a caller long-time listener
thank you
mom um i have a question though like um
because i always ask is that like them
because you don't have like president
anti-matter facts and everything i also
are kinds of pro vaccinations but what i
always ask everybody to get a good
answer for is that like
what's the end goal like
because if you're not going to get the
vaccination you're probably going to get
over
your angle just to get covered and
survive yeah
yeah that's it that that's that's their
that's basically their view i mean have
you asked them what do they say when you
ask them
they say
they literally try to they say like oh i
have it in the system or oh i'm scared
of the shot like like like
i got well i got the johnson one and
like that it hurt yeah but the thing is
though it's like it's just something you
you
like i always try to feel like though i
don't know if you have any like um i
don't want to
censor like quit being you know a b word
about it and just take it
yeah when people i have a question when
you say that you got the vaccine and it
hurt are you talking about the moment
they inject you it hurts like the little
prick from the needle hurts or are you
talking about like later you had arm
pain or whatever
yeah both you know like like the moment
they don't like it's like as a shock but
you're fine but then after that like i
had arm pain and i had two fevers but
after
after the vaccination
but
after that like after that done day i
was just fine i was just like i'm just
sore yeah like i get that there's
there's a fear of
needles and that's a specific thing but
when people say
getting the shot hurts i mean it's
literally one second i i they they put
the shot in
is maybe it's three seconds that part i
don't get like i get the fear of needles
that some people have that's a widely
known thing
i get
not wanting to feel sick for a few hours
or a day or two or whatever flu like but
the actual pain of the shot i don't get
because it's it's under five seconds you
know it's that part is strange to me
that that would make someone not get
vaccinated
yeah and not only that but my second
question is that like
like you have
like i think you probably have like this
question asked many times but i don't
want to repeat it but uh you'll have
like um
republicans were like elect the
republicans were against the vaccine
mandate
any measures to like really like even
mass mandate measures
to um
mitigate the spread of the virus is it
do you think
do you think could be a good political
strategy for the democrats to say these
people these
these people like wanda scientists are
like pro covet they're they're they're
against every measure to mitigate code
but they're pro code but they want yeah
we've talked about that a little bit
before i mean maybe you know it's really
a rhetorical trick to say that some of
these people are pro covet i don't think
it'll really catch on very much but
sometimes i'll say it it's like some
some of these people are some of the
biggest supporters of the virus that
that i've ever seen i don't know that
it's going to be any big kind of game
changer in terms of getting people to
take things seriously but you're right
it's almost like do they are they trying
to spread the virus via their policy um
but i don't think it'll make a big
difference to adopt that as a rhetorical
trick
all right well that's pretty much what
happens today all right thank you i
appreciate the call thank you so much
great to hear from you
some great great calls this week
uh why don't we go next to
christian from california christian
you're on the air
hi david can you hear me yes i can
so i was wondering with the
big kerfuffle made this week from joe
manchin coming out and saying he will
not vote for the 3.5 trillion
infrastructure bill yeah do you think
mansion overall is is sort of bad optics
for senate democrats
well yeah i mean so so the the
complicated thing is like of course he
is
but remember that almost certainly if
mansion is replaced in virginia it's
with a republican so he does vote with
democrats on a lot of things and it gets
us back to this age-old question of
okay you primary him and he loses
but then you almost certainly end up
with a republican so yeah i can't stand
the guy
we predicted he was all of a sudden
going to be front and center in a lot of
these policy decisions
i but then you also have to understand
the practicality of west virginia and
who's likely to replace mansion and it's
most most likely going to be a
republican who supports what democrats
want to do even less the solution is
less about
remove mansion because that probably
means a republican replaces him it's
we've got to win more seats back in
other states
um and also in pan with that i think we
should
you know work on on moving you know
imagine constituents to the left so that
absolutely forced to vote in a way that
you know reflects the will then
and also i would say
let's try to figure out a way for there
to be political consequences for mansion
from from being obstinate
do you think because i do tend to agree
with you that um if you know if you ran
a progressive type like aoc candidate in
west virginia that seat would probably
just go to a republican right but i mean
do you think that has more to do with
the rights framing of progressive type
democrats or like i don't see how you
know mansion
if you were to come out aggressively for
this 3.5 trillion dollar bill how that
in any way would harm them and what
you're doing you know i completely i i
on this particular bill i totally agree
with you i think it's less about
you know i i do think that i mean the
problem would be if aoc beats manchin in
a primary aoc loses in the general that
so it's really problems that would exist
in the general i do think it's possible
for a sort of working class type guy
like for example
tim ryan from ohio who's a member of
congress he's quite
left
but
he has kind of like the working-class
um middle-class creds with regard to his
whole approach
that's the type of guy that if he were
to primary and he doesn't live in west
virginia this is just a hypothetical tim
ryan's someone i could see maybe winning
an election in west virginia at the
state senate level but i'm i'm not even
sure it's a tough question it's a tough
one
yeah it is all right um well thank you
so much for your time david enjoy the
rest of your day appreciate it yeah
thank you so much for the call it's a
good question important to understand
the dynamics there i mean uh very very
important